[Music]
thank you for being here oh thank you
for wanting to screen it it's a big
honor and uh congrats on the film i love
it thank you
i'm so excited to talk to you about it
um
i mean to start
i'm caught in that final moment
uh that last monologue on regret is so
powerful
and it's interesting like the
sorry to start at the end i love it you
have
uh sounds fresh
like the backward looking emotions right
you have that earlier monologue on
vengeance how you're talking about how
it's like this impulse looking backwards
thank you for picking that up is also
kind of a backwards looking
so that the twinning of regret and then
you see the final title card vengeance
it's i'm just curious to hear you
absolutely i mean i'm so glad you picked
that up because some of the things that
matter to me i don't need the audience
to capture consciously it's great if
they do but it just is my own
guidepost to writing but to me
vengeance is a reckoning with regret
that is what ben is trying to put his
finger on and he says it he circles it
when he says vengeance is
not about the future it's only about the
past it is strange that it is an impulse
that we have that leads to no reward it
is only about correcting something that
is driving us crazy and
his regret is really what he confronts i
mean that what he does at the end i
think is really a rejection
of
who he has been that's who he really
wants to to kill now these are all just
the things that matter to me in my mind
they may not matter
or even be true to an audience but since
you asked as i was writing it absolutely
it's a reckoning with regret and when
she says that at the end
okay that she has transcended vengeance
she is thinking um it's all regrets just
keep going and this is a guy also with
with the john mayer scene you know it
goes by quickly at the beginning but
he's ben says fear of commitment is fear
of regret
um
so
you know in the funny way
regret
and commitment
are
are similar if you commit to things
you're going to regret things and and
the actions ben takes at the end are
commitments of a sort so yeah regret is
the theme of the movie
interesting
um
so i'd love to hear you talk a bit about
writing the script when i'm curious when
you when you got the idea when you
started writing on it
writing it and what that process was
like well the aesthetic thing uh i saw a
poster for a movie called vengeance
directed by johnny toe starring johnny
halliday and uh i thought i'd like to be
in a movie called vengeance and i
thought yeah the the thing that kind of
made me smile and and almost laugh was
like i'm not supposed to be in a movie
called vengeance i knew the exact tone
if it was me bj novak finch it's like we
know it's different it's not it's like
everything i do
are you kidding or not you know is the
tone and i was like that's a cool tone
but i didn't really think of doing
anything for it and then i was in the
midst of a terrible bout of regret a
number of years ago when i just broken
up with someone and that i had a
was terrible partner too
and um completely ignored the
relationship when it happened afterwards
i'm looking at all the photos i'm
regretting and obsessing and i thought
well
the story kind of developed from that
what if a person were called
in
and and after the fact
got very deeply invested in a
relationship so the comedic version of
it was you we have to avenge her death
but you know all the things like meeting
the family that you don't do in the
moment and that's really what ben is
trying to pitch at the beginning with
this divided times thing to to issa
rae's character he's on to something too
but it's he has to actually live it
right right
it's so interesting to hear you
expressing in terms of
like your personal story that led you to
write it because in watching this
it also to me feels very much written in
the moment i mean obviously you've been
working on this for a while but it feels
culturally like very much of the moment
that we're in right now and in the
recent past in terms of what he's going
through
the new yorker in texas and everything
going on politically and culturally
well i love that it feels like written
sort of
was it a fast writing process for you or
was it no it was it was very slow and
then the development process was slowly
paused for cove but it's one of those
weird movies that i think became more
timely the the longer we waited
you know it just the country kept
um devolving into these um and you know
we we
especially by the end we could respond
to things on set it you know wasn't
actually filmed or edited that long ago
but
it was written in a time where where i
thought america
was um was falling apart um how young we
all were
but i did know okay i mean i knew we all
knew for a long time there's really kind
of two americas
and the idea of someone from one being
pulled into the other and being forced
to sit at a dinner table
with people to think he's one of them
emotionally anyway i knew it would be
funny to take him to a red state and
somewhere very different but that's i
had no idea how how far
how i had no idea how topical the movie
would become yeah what i do like is that
it stayed in the emotional realm of that
and with phineas o'connell the great
music producer uh wrote the score and
when he handed in the score for that
fight outside whataburger it cracked i
feel what that scene was supposed to be
about because that's the part that
really felt like a political argument in
the script on the screen it feels like
an emotional argument yeah and i think
that's the key to the movie that it
isn't really about the politics it's
about what it feels like to be on
opposite sides of a divide that's it's
i'm glad you brought that scene up it's
one of my favorite in the film it's
it's an incredible i mean for all of you
in it but for your performance there i
thought was like you're letting it all
out in that moment with him
and
yeah you're right it does it is a
it's an
emotional human scene it doesn't feel
overtly political but
it's all there it occurred to me
afterwards that i think it's the most
intimate scene in the movie even though
it is a fight because
you're you're so polite the first scene
is warm but
you're very polite when you meet
someone's parents and if you're if
you're avoiding confrontation it's not
intimate if you're storming out it's not
intimate real intimacy is a fight like
that right and um and i felt that was
the actors who brought it and a lot of
these things by the way it's because
i've seen this movie so many times now i
realize that after the fact it's not
like i explained to everyone here's the
five levels
you know your intuition carries you
through
and then you realize why certain things
worked
um so tonally i think this film is so
interesting and and complicated i'm not
sure i can quite articulate it but
like
it's comedic but i was saying this to
you before we in the green room i i find
it very unsettling watching it like at
first i'm laughing and then like i'm
laughing you're kind of obscuring these
different cultural tropes and things but
then it's like wait a minute i feel like
i'm you know then it sort of turns
where i'm like i'm the one being secured
as like a participant in this culture
and um you know seeing myself reflected
on screen
and then also with your character i feel
like you know
just a wildly unreliable narrator right
where i'm drawn in by you i'm like oh
i'm laughing with bj novak but then
you're saying and doing these like very
questionable things as well
so it's like as the fish out of water i
want to go with you and and be on that
journey with you but then your own
instincts your character's instincts are
so
questionable at times that it's it's
really i don't know it's i love the ride
of going on that with you but i'm
curious
sort of how you approach that in both
the writing and in the directing
uh well as with everything in my life i
blame john mayer
um no um i um
you know i i did feel that sort of
as a personal exploration okay what do i
what do i like most about myself or or
what do i hope most about myself and
what do i hate most about myself so on
the personal journey was like how do i
take him from point a to point b um but
in terms of the tone you know
it made sense to me the whole time and
it's why i felt i had to direct it and
it's also why i felt i had to act in it
because i was like i know there's better
actors out there i know there's better
directors but i can just i can show you
the tone and you'll get it and and the
one moment that people kept lobbing me
to cut because they were like it's not
going to work was the schindler's list
joke in the truck
and i was like trust me i'm going to
make it work and when it works the whole
movie will work
um so i was always focused on that even
in the edit bay when we had much bigger
fish to fry and that scene was basically
working i was like cut two frames here
add add one frame there different
reaction shot just i wanted that to
really work perfectly because that was
my proof of concept a movie that could
be
um
sort of funny but also uncomfortable and
very now but very you know all of those
things came into that joke
yeah
um
could you talk a bit about it's an
incredible cast starting with john mayer
of course but also i mean this is one of
my favorite things i've ever seen ashton
kutcher do oh he's like
excellent in this yeah and i'm uh
would love to hear sort of how you i
know you've you worked with him back
years ago on on punk yeah i felt
comfortable with him because i worked
with him on punch although in a way i
didn't because he was i was 24 and had
never acted before i was a stand-up and
i got an audition through that for mtv
for punk'd which at the time was the
hottest possible thing to be a part of
on mtv and
um ashton was the hottest celebrity in
the world you know wearing the trucker
hats and it started a craze like he
could just do no wrong and he was he was
so cool and actually the suits he wears
in this movie are partly inspired by the
fact that i saw him walking on ventura
boulevard on one of our shoots wearing
like a pinstripe suit just draped over
him and i had never seen an adult wear a
suit that wasn't like an accountant you
know i was like someone could wear a
suit by choice to be cool and and so i
knew he'd be wearing cool suits in the
movie but amazing suits yeah i was
always intimidated uh by him but also
felt comfortable having worked with him
and then when i wrote this character i
knew okay well this is a guy
he needs to what he needs to do for the
story is very difficult he needs to be
an easy target for ben on the way in and
we think ben is gonna ben thinks he's
gonna make fun of this guy
and he's gonna be a joke then he has to
be someone that ben thinks this is a guy
smarter than me who i'm looking up to
for advice i'm completely
everything's turned on and said about
texas about my myself everything has to
turn and
then you have the reason
that was so important doubly is because
when you see ashton kutcher in the
middle of the movie you assume he's the
bad guy
and so i worked very hard to make it
seem like perhaps this was one of those
one scene cameos right in the middle and
really wrap his narrative up
so to have a character like that but
that that was after the fact have a
character like that who can be so
underestimated and then so brilliant to
a character who already is pretty
intellectual
ashton was
was the perfect
person for it because
he is so smart he is a tech investor he
is a tv producer when you talk to him
he's hypnotic uh but people know him
from like dude where's my car in that
70s show so he's easy to underestimate
which he's made a whole career of and i
knew him i knew that other side of him
and i thought if i
am the first guy to show everybody this
i'll get a lot of credit
um and and so that's that's really why
yeah it could only have been him that's
brilliant no i thought he was amazing he
was amazing um and he nailed it right
away
and the first assembly i saw of this
movie they say the first assembly is
going to make you want to kill yourself
no matter what that the editor hands in
and it did except for
that scene was almost the same those
scenes were almost the same as in the
cut they were just so obvious there's no
way to cut it wrong yeah yeah yeah
could you also talk a bit about casting
the family down in texas because that's
like an amazing little ensemble right
there i mean it was jay smith yeah
thanks um
that took a long time um i really wanted
the movie this to feel dynamic and
non-obvious
and it's sort of a theme of the movie
unlikely people together and the tones
unlikely tones together so i wanted the
cast to feel
like an unusual electrical um
you know
wires
uh too many wires was a good uh good
goal for me so
uh
sharon
i had never seen succession when i cast
her and so i didn't know she played this
like new york lawyer i could and so she
just played this texas mom she has this
amazing
career in theater dove cameron
also just auditioned
and i did not know who she was either
and then i googled her and she has like
50 million followers on instagram and it
actually made me suspicious i'm like
maybe this was a fluke i don't know if
she's much of a serious actor so i had
her do it again right and she was even
better she has this amazing comedic
timing
and isabella amara i guess these were
just auditions but i just auditioned
people a lot el stupido is a local
albuquerque kid who is like really
psyched to be in a movie but also really
psyched that he went um four for four in
his little league the other day and he
sends the cast videos of that
so he's like a real wholesome kid luanne
stevens
also auditioned she plays granny and she
had been the grand friday night lights
so you know she had done that before
jay smith had done nothing like that
before
um but they fit very and boyd of course
boyd holbrook is like a real actor's
actor
never done comedy before from kentucky
you know he had some elements of it so
luanne really led us through a group
rehearsal and bonding session the first
day we were there
and then we were you know two days at
that little table so we got to know each
other but it was a wonderful rhythm
um so i know you've directed quite a bit
prior to this um
on the office and other other shows but
this is your first feature
and
you talked about this a little bit why
you knew you you wanted to direct this
particular film but i'm just curious to
hear you talk a bit more about
your interest in directing in general
like what what do you like about it and
how was this experience for you doing
doing a full
feature um
what i like about it
um is that to me it feels like a
three-dimensional form of writing it
feels like writing was a limited version
of writing i think writing is the wrong
word for writing you know people think
of it as spelling or
we grow up thinking of it as spelling
tests and handwriting tests and so we
get up all on our heads about the words
on the page it's not about that it's
about imagination and expression so
this you know i've always been you know
a type and write the words writer
but
i i've realized the more and more i've
worked there's
in terms of
ideating what's on the screen
sure there are the words but who you
cast
is an enormous dimension to it and how
you shoot it and what music you put
behind it so i don't think of that as a
separate skill i think of that as the
continuation of writing
and the more i've done the more i
realized that i was fortunate on the
office and the other things i've
directed that generally all that had
already been done for me they cast these
amazing actors they have the set you
show up and you know directing tv i've
said sometimes is sort of like
playing
um a video game in an arcade when you
don't have a quarter when you're a kid
and you're going like that to try to
imagine that you're playing um but
you know in a film you have to invent
all that and it was just another way to
to write really
interesting
um
was the so you were shoot you mentioned
this earlier but you were shooting
and then
covet happened
prior to covet happened tom hanks day
was um
the day before um
uh the day after we shot the rodeo so we
did three out of five weeks
and then we shut down yeah and i did not
like i would call people in la and
they'd be like it's getting weird i'm
like what the fuck are you talking about
like i'm in a red state like no one's
saying anything ashton emails me two
weeks before he's shooting he's like are
you still filming due to covet 19. i'm
like who is this tech nerd up in his own
ass i i was offended i i just wrote back
yes like he's not going to show what is
he talking about first of all it's
called corona second
and um of course the day before he was
going to shoot the whole production was
shut down um so
um so how long did you go we were down
for seven months
um we didn't know when we'd be back we
didn't know if we'd be back we didn't
know if we'd survive i mean it was a
crazy time and the movie was sort of the
least of it but um blumhouse put the
team back together right as they were
starting to go back on succession and
all the other things
and we got back seven months later and
it was actually kind of a gift because i
had gotten to see the footage and edit
it and uh it's not really that we change
anything but there were a few moments i
could drop a few pickups i could get i
could kind of learn more what was
working i i think it was a little more
of a um
a little more of a square comedy a bit
because i didn't totally trust the drama
i felt a little shy
to be emotional and i saw that the
emotional stuff really worked the stuff
with el stupido and everyone liked the
feeling of the family and so that
encouraged me to go a little further
so it was nice to get to stop i
encourage anyone who makes a movie to
take a seven month break
kind of think about things
and then come back it's really elegant
if you can get people to pay for that
wow that's amazing you got everyone back
that's fantastic yeah yeah
wow and you just when you shut down
i mean you you were shooting in in new
mexico and everyone just left and
uh yeah i mean we got out of there
hanging out right yeah yeah wow but you
didn't lose locations or
we we did lose a couple locations but it
we were able to accommodate everything
pretty well wow people were really happy
to be back you know even with the masks
and i gotta say ashton insisted on daily
testing instead of three times a week
which was the industry standard at the
time and every other new mexico
production was shut down
except ours wow
yeah that's great smart guy
um
but
just
another question on directing so i'm
curious for you so i get what you're
saying about this being like viewing
this as an extension of writing but what
is that for you i'm curious what what
the onset experience is like for you and
or is there a particular type of
atmosphere you like to create on the set
or like coming from that's in chaotic
tense and chaotic a little
little menacing um i like uh and you
know i think it was actually helpful
because because i had to be
um both sides of the camera i had to be
calm and i had to be the same person
behind the camera that i was in it a
little bit so
um i think that sort of calmness i was
forced to be calm yeah and so that also
meant the person in the scene was
relatively calm
as an anchor but i think that keeping
the the level of being on the brink of
improv being on the brink of breaking is
something i learned on the office you
know on the office when people would
improvise often the improv wouldn't make
it but the fact that everyone might be
improvising at any second kept it very
alive and kept it very honest
so i liked um you know really
encouraging the conversations uh with
the actors to go
smoothly in and out but we also had a
very very good crew the director of
photography really um
sets the tone for the crew as the first
ad and we really had wonderful sort of
captains on both sides
the film it looks beautiful i was going
to ask about the the dp in your
relationship with him had you worked
together before or was this your first
no that was our first time together um
he's a wonderful and fast and
cinematographer but another great thing
about him lynne moncrief is that
everybody likes him
and that matters a lot because that
means that crew respects him and crew
will go the extra mile and if he
explains something they'll listen
and um you know a lot of a lot of the
set is sort of the org chart in a sense
in a creative sense and so i learned
that that sort of leadership
matters a lot
yeah absolutely
um you mentioned the composer um
but i also wanted to ask the music in
the film is fantastic and for some
reason i really towards the end you have
the lana del rey stuff yeah and i'd love
for you to talk about
lana del rey in this movie feels very
important to the final sequence and just
uh
um well why it matters to me in the
movie that isn't said in the movie is
that when quentin is talking about we
don't hear people's voices anymore
you're a playlist guy my one exception
is lana del rey that's the voice i
listen to so i do think of her as an
actual voice that has something to say
and the line at the beginning about lana
and i love america not in that faded
lana del ray way i think i grapple with
is america a ghost of itself that is
really a sentimental value
um an ironic sort of faded glory which i
hate to think it might be and that is
sort of what is beautiful about lana del
rey's music and about that song which is
american
and um and it's a tragic song it's a
tragic operatic song about exactly what
ben hoped wouldn't be
um
wouldn't be the case about him in
america yeah um so i it was it was very
hard to get that song for various
reasons
but lana helped us a lot actually at the
end that's great um
well
thank you so much for being here
congrats on the film it opens in one
week
yeah so tell everyone to go see this i
don't even need two you they already saw
it so they won't
but yeah if you guys do i'm thank it
means a lot to me to be here so thank
you very much for having me and thank
you very much for for wanting to check
it out absolutely thank you dj novak
fan of the university of texas
and who here is a fan of texas town
what if she was murdered
this just keeps getting bigger and
bigger looks like two pairs of prince
cowboy boots calling out an apb to find
two men wearing cowboy boots
[Laughter]
what happened to her why do you care so
much why do you care so little
you're so lucky in you evelyn i really
don't know what you saw i mean heart
caesar
texas has a full width
you can't solve something like this with
a 45. it's the breakdown of society is
what it is it gets women i think that's
very nice you're going to need a
12-gauge couple of ars no western
automatic and a sidearm for safety
where are you right now uh i'm in an
uber
[Music]
you